i didn't even know they were natives i
thought they were mexicans when i first
saw themselves man
because we don't got a lot and i saw
them on the street like some homeless
mexicans i've never seen a homeless
mexican in my entire life
like that's shocking because back home
like if a mexican was homeless
he would just build a home right like
that's that's what they do
they i'll figure it out tomorrow and
then there's a home right
they're already at home depot this [ __ ]
is right there the home is
i remember i was here one winter man it
was cold as [ __ ] right downstairs from
my airbnb there was this native dude he
was [ __ ] sleeping outside
and i was like oh my god this is crazy i
gotta help this [ __ ] out
i went up to him i was like bro it's
freezing out can i get you a blanket or
something
and he looked at me he was like
i'm not falling for that again
[Music]
that's how we got here in the first
place
thank you but i am sorry i cannot in
good conscience accept this award
on behalf of melissa mccarthy i instead
have chosen to give my time to a friend
who has something very important to say
my name is johnny two feathers
while you enjoy tonight's show i want
you to think about something
the spot where you're sitting every
square foot of ground in this country
was stolen from my ancestors and after
you stole it
you murdered them so you'll forgive us
if we do not laugh along there is
nothing funny
about the extermination of a people
the theater stinks of blood that's all i
have to say
both johnny two feathers everybody
johnny two feathers give away
johnny a giant on a wave all right well
donny two feathers everybody
i really think that white people are
from like another planet
because we like when we came to america
it was so nice
it was just indians and they weren't
even indians
we called them that by accident and we
still call them that like we knew in a
month that it wasn't indians
but we just don't give a [ __ ]
we came here they're like hi and we're
like hey you're indians right
and they're like no no this is india
right
no it's not it's totally other place
you're not indians
no ah you're indians
you're indians for hundreds of years
after
we ruined everything here this was the
great it was just coast to coast just
green and brown and beautiful
and and all the humans were just walking
around
with painted faces just walking and
they'd be like oh
that looks yummy and then they just eat
from the ground and then they'd sleep on
the grass
and they wake up and they [ __ ] and then
they'd go for a swim and do a little
dance that was the whole continent
was just folks doing that
i mean there was people in mexico
cutting off kids heads and rolling them
down the pyramid stairs
but that's i mean
that's that's gonna that's always going
on what are you gonna you can't
you can't do a whole lot about that
what i feel real bad for is is indians
everybody feels bad for indians they get
dog they get dogged openly because
everybody thinks they're dead
these [ __ ] are not all dead all
right i've seen with my own eyes i've
seen a gathering of 1500
native americans they were all gathered
in one place
the place is called walmart in new
mexico
because indians ever i've never seen
indians before i wasn't even sure if
they were indians i was [ __ ] up but
i asked one of them it's not nice but i
seen him in the sports section
looking at bows and arrows i had to say
something excuse me
[Applause]
cause i i don't mean to be rude um
are you an indian and he was cool yes
yes i'm indian still didn't believe him
i had to test him to be sure this was
[ __ ] up but i had a gum wrapper in my
pocket
so i balled that [ __ ] up and i threw it
on the floor
and a single tear came out his eye said
oh [ __ ]
i had so many questions
what trap are you from
i am a navajo
i said word
i studied you in social studies
you're a hunter gatherer correct
he said i guess so
that's what you wish to call it i said
why what do you call it
he said i am an alcoholic
[Applause]
i said well what's your name dog he said
please
dog is my cousin that was a good guess
my name is
running coyote what is your name friend
and that [ __ ] caught me off guard i mean
i didn't want to say my name was dave
to a [ __ ] named running coyote
this don't feel good enough he just put
me on the spot
i said huh my name what
oh my name's uh blackfeet
then i change the subject forget about
me what's going on with you
i want to meet your chief why don't me
you and your chief and your friends get
together tonight we could have a real
live peace pipe smoking ritual we need
to celebrate [ __ ] i thought you were
dead
and he set it up it was beautiful it was
just like our dream was all sitting
around
indians was beating the drum
some other indians came out the back
with a long blanket that was folded in
half and put in
in front of us
open that [ __ ] up and on the blanket was
a long wooden pipe
with feathers and bags of weed were all
over the blanket
chief walked over
the big ones are 50. the little ones are
25
and these are 10.
me and those indians got high as [ __ ]
i was big i told the chief he was
talking i cut him off timeout chief
sorry to interrupt [ __ ] smash man the
weeds too strong
i'm itching this is pcp the spirits have
got me
chief the spirits have got me
and the chief threw some water in my
face calm down blackface
splash i said hey it's black feet
[ __ ] take it easy
blackfeet you're welcome to stay amongst
me and my tribe for the night
until the spirits leave you
and they gave me my own tp to sleep in
which sounds nice i personally felt like
it was a little [ __ ] up
you know cause they all had houses man
it's like why can't i sleep with y'all
in the house and watch tv like i can't
be on this grass all night
[Applause]
my favorite day of the year is
thanksgiving and i am literally
celebrating
a day white people killed an entire race
of people that they thought was me
now yeah
that's solid like you got to be pretty
nice at racism at the very least
that i don't even give a [ __ ] like i'm
not giving this up i'm not sitting out
thanksgiving yeah yeah yeah i'm not
sitting out an
entire month of pumpkin flavored [ __ ]
yeah suck my dick
[ __ ] that son you willing
yo but here's the thing probably judging
white people's racism
here's what's inside this is this one
annoys me about thanksgiving
when people go we're celebrating a day
where white people took out an entire
race of people we're not
celebrating that they were dining
they said we're celebrating the dying
we're celebrating the day before it's
the calm before the storm
and maybe if you knew how to cook a
[ __ ] turkey you wouldn't get take out
i think that deer ain't slap i think the
native americans built up that dinner
and the white people were like all right
we ain't gonna kill these [ __ ]
they come through the cranberry sauce
no but they put y'all on the corn though
and you'll be loving some corn fam
corn is killing us that's their ultimate
payback
that's the long-term payback of native
americans this corn is out here giving
us diabetes
it's out here giving us cancer play that
[ __ ] too slow that's all they did they
did a slow game
chief slow foot
chief long view
cheap missing toe